in one week marvel  comes back to the movies you're going to  give me some hero speech  speeches aren't really my thing black  widow ready pg-13 experience it july 9.  let's go  just don't make a scene you made a scene  didn't you what is with this tension  black widow windy pg-13 get tickets  ordered on disney plus july 9.  the hell is that guy taskmaster he can  mimic anyone he's ever seen  he controls the whole army of widows got  to be stopped  lucky us i want to break something  you got fat smelly water away  black widow radius pg-13 tickets and  pre-orders available now experiencing  july 9th  natasha you're not just a spy  but an avenger  i couldn't be more proud of you you  smell really bad  on july 9th what brings you home we have  unfinished business  the experience still fits  will be worth the wait  let's go marvel studios black widow  windy pg-13  tickets and pre-orders available now  july 9.  you